[Applause]
uh good evening everybody my name is
john horn i'm the host of the frame on
kpcc
thank you
um before we start a panel a couple
quick announcements uh to keep in
accordance with the academy rules please
don't take photographs or videos during
the panel discussion
and i also would like to
recognize that this downstage event is
supported in part by the california arts
council if you want more information
please go to arts.ca.gov
let's get going with our panel
uh let's bring up producer peter burrell
actor alma martinez
[Applause]
a better looking actor than tony plan
rose portillo
actor edward james almost
[Applause]
and writer director luis valdez
[Applause]
uh i'm very curious how many people came
out here to see i am joaquin
show of hands there you go
i mean i think there is a direct line
that we need to address between el
teatre camposino and i am joaquin and
zoot suit so luis tell us about why one
begat the other and why that film led us
to where we are today
i am joaquin yes i am joaquin was uh my
first film literally it started out as a
slideshow with el tietro campesino
it started out as a poem actually by the
great uh corki gonzalez you know rudolfo
gonzalez
one of the icons of the chicano movement
long since deceased a few years now but
uh
this uh
we were in denver in 1967 summer 67 he
handed me a a
mimeograph copy of uh type copy of his
poem
brought it home read it finally and i
was totally moved so i called him and
asked permission i said can we do it
live can i just recite this life
and he said sure
and we started doing it with
50 slides to begin with and kept adding
slides and it just kept getting more and
more
complex the live all of the music was
originally produced on the stage live by
members of the theatre compass composing
the voices all of that i did the
narrative obviously and um
eventually uh a friend of mine who was a
photographer
george ballas who's
the cinematographer on this
um
i don't know if you know what do you
know his name yeah in 69 he bought a 16
millimeter bolex camera and he says why
don't we take your slideshow turn it
into a movie
and i said great but there's no money
and he said don't worry about that what
he did is he hocked uh one of his cars
and for five thousand dollars and then
he set up shop in a kitchen in fresno in
literally at the kitchen table he put a
frosted
old window kitchen window with the
bullets camera anchored on one side and
then the slide projector on the other
and so we shot
shot by shot we made a a record of the
narrative so we work with that to begin
with and shot by shot shot by shot we
composed it over a weekend in fresno
and uh and then it became uh the 16
millimeter film we exhibited it in our
show in fresno uh in 1970 for the first
time made in 69 uh premiered in 70 and
it was like a thunderbolt
it was like a lightning bolt and and
people were totally bowled over by it
and became one of the staples of the
chicano movement so
a tribute i think to corki's poem but
also to the power of the collaboration
right yes absolutely so how do you get
from the central valley to the mark
taper forum
because that's a big jump both
geographically and professionally
uh the link actually was done uh we were
based in san juan about eastern 1971
we're still there
and
peter brook in 1973 came and brought his
whole company from paris
distinguished actors from all over the
world
uh they came there was a group about 30
that came again on their dime
but they they worked with us for that
summer in the three months that they
were in the united states two were in
san juan we worked off the floor of our
old warehouse there was a 26 year old
blonde uh
very attractive blonde by the name of
helen mirren
and actually she she tattooed her hand
at the end of the summer it's the
movement it's the pachuco symbol
and uh she still has it you know she she
covers it with makeup play the queen in
england or something but anyway
we held workshops and that's when i met
gordon davidson he came and he said well
if if peter brooke is working with you
it must be something
so he invited the theater to perform in
74 at the at the taper and we we did uh
ten days four days on it and phil do you
remember tell us huh
ten days yes phyllis parson take a bow
phil it's one of my producers long time
producer
here we go
and so we we we filmed it and um i mean
uh we connected with uh gordon and then
he invited me he the carpa
de los las cuatros was a piece of one of
our standard pieces in the 70s and from
there he invited me back in 77
to
begin a new thing that he wanted to do
with new theater for now stories about
los angeles right and so he invited me
to write and direct a new piece and uh
we both had the same idea actually he
was very interested in the zoot riots
and i had been carrying a pamphlet that
had been given to me by david sanchez of
the brown berets uh way back in the 68.
i looked at it in 68 was very moved
guyandor's hollywood uh
pamphlet in defense of the sleepy lagoon
trying to raise money and uh i said this
is powerful stuff but it was 1968.
martin luther king had just been
assassinated bobby kennedy who worked on
his campaign that summer was had just
subsequently assassinated it was not a
time for me to sit down and write a play
it took nine years 10 years actually
to
get to the point where zuchu premiered
at the taper wow once it was a taper
then the possibility of going to
broadway and making a movie was possible
edward i want to ask you about where you
were in your career and uh before i came
up here i looked to see where you were
in your career before this play opened
uh you had a movie called bogart in 1974
junkie in bathroom
uh you had a movie in 1975 aloha bobby
rose chicano number one
and then a movie in 1977 called alan
priesta first drunk
so when you see this work by this man
come on your desk it's got to be an
amazing feeling to see what luis has
offered you
it was um amazing to be honest with you
i've never seen anything like it
the opening monologue
killer
and all that that was the very first
thing i ever saw he only uh when i when
we went to audition it was a cattle call
and i'll never forget i was asked i was
actually
at the bar taper
auditioning for the american messenger
service which was a
play that they were going to do six days
with book in hand
and i lost the the role to rudy ramos
as i was walking out the door
uh i got i stopped to watch look at one
of the
uh
boards that was there yeah
and uh right at the hall and the voice
hauls from one of the rooms hey you
turn around and look and they go yeah
you yeah you you you look like you you
should it's exactly i still to the t
verbatim hey you yeah you look
you you want to be in a play
i walked the door saying oh yeah yeah oh
then then uh you come come tomorrow one
o'clock
i said okay so i came at one o'clock i
parked my truck i had furniture in it
delivering furniture all over the city
that's i used to stay alive
and i there was 300 guys there
it was a cattle call
and they would and the milt hammer
gave me a piece of paper everybody was
holding this little piece of paper all
the guys there was nothing but guys here
at that moment
and
they gave me a piece of paper and i
started to read it and
and i i said oh my god
i was in shock
because i had heard
this language when i was growing up
on the streets it was called
but it was pachuco slang it was just the
stuff that the kids on the street that
were really badass kids
talked and it was a language that like
everyone later found out it was meant so
that no one could understand it
not the spanish-speaking not the
english-speaking nobody and they would
talk their own thing and they had their
own thing and i was saying
the [ __ ] what the heck does that mean
watcha
you know w-h-a-t-c-h-a
watcha
it was it was written out fanatically it
was beautiful i'd never seen it written
nor had i ever heard
myself ever say it and i was saying
i had no idea what that was takucha
and then and so i read it and then it
got past the calor and it said
in in
in parentheses it said the actor
the topic was the pachuco
then halfway down it just in he says the
actor
and he said ladies and gentlemen the
play you're about to see is a construct
the fact that i said what the hell is
this
i said you know i had no concept it was
i'd never seen anything like it
and so i walked in and there was uh phil
and esparza and there was danny and
milt no milt was outside uh there was
about four other people in the room but
luis wasn't there this day i'd gone back
up north yeah and we couldn't find the
pachuco
so i ended up walking in and i read it
out loud and
just read it literally you couldn't do
anything else
to do it correctly you just had to read
it because nobody could perform it it
was just beyond anything it was just
get through it that was the key you know
if you could get through it you were
back
and i can you and so i got through it i
said it and it came out
really kind of
intensely
understood by you know just because i
was so at that moment i had done theater
okay you're being kind to yourself
because the reality is that that it was
a familiar language it was a sound that
was familiar to all there was a
musicality to it and you tapped into
what you hadn't seen written
but you
heard it come out of your mouth and you
knew what to do
yeah well i mean the tone there was
there was a rhythm and i i knew the
rhythm i had heard it my whole life i
was born in the streets of east l.a on
the corner of first indiana
because of my
and my i was born to a wonderful lady
who's sitting in the audi one audience
my mother mom can you can you sneak up
mom can you stand up she's hard for her
to hear
she's 91 years young
[Applause]
but needless to say i said it and then i
i went home but when i walked out the
door listened to this and you came back
literally
but as i was walking out the door
i did something and that i i'm so
grateful that i did it
i folded the piece of paper as i was
going towards the door because it was a
huge room in the
a studio at the uh mark taper
at the
so i went back and as i was folding it
up i put it in my pocket my breast
pocket and as i was walking out the door
and milt says give me the paper
i said oh i left it in the deck i left
on top of the table
that's oh okay and so i left
and i went to my truck and i was like
getting in the truck i pulled out the
paper and i said man i'm going to learn
this
i want to memorize this okay and i'm
going to come back you know to see who
got the role
see how good this person went because
really it and you are perfectly 1 000
correct
the moment
i saw that piece of paper
the moment i read it
and i read the the other part i said
this is one of a kind and this is it
this is the beginning
and we had waited for a long time i'd
been doing theater for 14 years i
started in
1964. this was 1978.
okay i'd done every off off off
la theater that there was in l.a and and
that's far off of broadway i got to tell
you
i'm not kidding man so and you know i
was working at the time i was working
for a year at the uh uh
lact at the la theater uh ralph wade's
place los angeles theater center i've
been working there for a year and i've
been doing perfume with
you know kennedy jim kennedy and uh was
so that's how i got a chance to go to
mark tabor wow and so with that in mind
one day
i get a phone call
about a month later and they said can
you come back for another audition and i
said oh [ __ ]
i said yeah i can but i started to think
where did i put that paper
what what the hell i didn't
remember i said oh [ __ ] where's the
paper
i said oh my shirt and i looked at my my
shirt i went up to my shirt that grabbed
i said i looked inside my shirt and it
was in the pocket
but it had been washed
[Laughter]
getting going
it was just so really it was so hard to
read and it was just all shredded and
wet and you know it had been washed many
times it'd be not warning them just so
anyway i i got it and i started that
night i started to read it so the next
day i walk in and this i was
i was you know up to my i didn't know
that luis was going to be there i wore
a
levi
jacket long and that's what i wore for
all the rehearsals remember
well my hat was levi
pork pie pork my hat made out of levi
material
and i had a levi
i don't know why i found this [ __ ]
a coat a coat down past my knees it was
a levi's coat i wore a levi's shirt and
levi pants
and black shoes
i swear to you and i walked into that
room and i never once cracked the smile
i never once
said hello to them
i walked in the room
bad as i could be
i mean forget it man i was a pachuca
from the street the way i saw them and i
walked in there and and they had and he
goes luis was sitting there he was kind
of quiet everybody was quiet they were
kind of like
what is this
and so i walked in and and he says are
you ready
yeah and i said just a minute
first word i ever said i didn't say
hello how are you by names that almost
and all nothing not
nothing
i looked at the paper
and i went and i get it and i threw it
away
[Laughter]
i went right into it man i walked up on
this close to the table man and there
was louisa and i threw it right at you i
just let all of the calor come right at
you
i went crazy i just lost it you know
really theatrical very big big it was
great apparently it worked yeah boy did
it ever was interesting a little
footnote there's i wrote the script uh
and i offered my brother a choice i said
you can either play hank
or you can play the pachuco
so we came to la to cast
and i was gone that day because we
couldn't find uh
uh the actor you know and i had to go
home uh
and uh but then he called me danny
called me and he says we found el
pachuco
and and so i came back and that's when i
met eddie ormus he had the quality you
can see it on the screen he had the
qualities of the young toshiro mifumi
he had the qualities of humphrey bogart
he had the car he had the quality of the
pachucos when you finally put it all
together
these are the the elements you know that
you need to do that but not everybody
could do the pachuco and so it would
tremend this is one of those fortuitous
events in the history of art all over
the world occasionally but the right
person at the right time and the
combination of danny and eddie was
tremendous you know it was right up on
the screen
so alma and rose there are a couple
things that happen
the play opens at the mark taper forum
and it's a huge hit and then it goes to
broadway and it's attracting an audience
that you don't typically see back then
at the mark tape reform and still don't
see today so to be a part of a
production that's not only doing
incredibly well but attracting an
audience that feels as if their stories
have not been told
those two things must be remarkable to
go through at the very same time
palpable
utterly utterly palpable from from the
very first audience
that that came in and it was like
oh my gosh
it was it was unbelievable
to to feel and i know alma was was
touring with el teatro
with campesino's stuff and then and then
we got to trade off
we got to trade off so so
i know that you walked into that exact
same
sentiment i have to tell you the funny
stories okay
so um it got so crazy i mean we were
selling i was at the aquarius by the way
they had gone to broadway and then i
took over uh de la roll de la's role uh
rose's role at the aquarius and then did
the film so they warned us you know the
crowd is rowdy so rather than having
ushers they were bouncers
and so oh that's sure
yeah
i remember one night it was really full
you know the show everybody's just with
us
and i see
walking up the aisle this bouncer with
the woman over his shoulder carrying her
out
and i went oh my goodness this is not
the theater that we're used to but i
think that's the exciting part i just
want to add
we were doing theater for people who've
never gone before because a lot of you
have gone and you know
you make reservations you call you get a
babysitter you know
dinner babies no everybody came and they
would show up you know without
reservations
and this is the thing they would come
all the way to hollywood and this is the
thing with latino audiences
we don't just see a play once
this was good let's go and bring that
tia let's bring the abuela
they would come multiple times but
what would happen is remember there's a
tradition for theater so they would come
but they didn't know any of the
tradition
so i think i remember a story wasn't it
one city because the stage was like this
where you could literally walk up and
they had that false ending and that's
the way
and what is it that's the way
this is the
story the story ends and then he goes
well at one night
i don't know if it was a night because
you ended up the performance at the
aquarius he came and did several last
performances well this man comes up
who's been drinking
and he goes that's the end of the
performance oh man that is so he walked
up to the stage and gave eddie a big hug
right
and the last anecdote is this so every
night remember we we're not used to
coming to places like this we're not
and so i'm from i was born in mexico i
was raised in pico rivera you know so
and so every night we go out to the
parking lot
um
tailgating get the beers
they were partying
in the parking lot every night before
they came in and after
so
that's just a small example of people
who aren't used to going to the theater
but those are the audiences that this
play attracted
and because it attracted those people
many people became theater patrons but
in the case of myself and a lot of
companies
we found our place
as artists we found our place in the
society i became an academic i found my
place i am a chicanas
and i think that's what this whole
experience not just for me but for a lot
of people and i thank the wonderful
artists
i thank the wonderful producers and i
thank luis who is
maximus
political activist
anyway gracias peter you have the job of
taking thank you
peter you have the job of taking what
luis has created on stage and put it on
film and there's so many different ways
you could adapt a story like this but
you chose a very traditional way to try
to capture the theatricality of it so
how did the film come about and what was
the mandate and what did luis want to
make sure was guaranteed in terms of the
way in which the story was going to be
told
well the film uh
really had its birth when gordon
davidson convinced the monkey mux at
universal that we've got to record this
remarkable play this is a piece of
history gordon was being touted as the
joe papp of los angeles and so forth
and so the original plan was to put
three cameras in the audience and film a
play well something very fortuitous
happened once we got our offices all set
up there were two strikes in 1981 and
1982 a writer's strike and an actor
strike
so we were in the offices and we were
all supposed to go home until it was
over and louis said well i got no place
to go i had no place to go so
let's just hang out here so in that time
we found bud smith a remarkable editor
done movies like putney swope and
rhinoceros and he found us jackie canvas
thank god you're here so great jackie
yeah a remarkable editor and tom john
who was a production designer who had
done theater and movies
and
david myers who was a traditional camera
but he also did woodstock he did the
port of john scene in woodstock but he
also did the last waltz
so we started gathering those people
because louise said i don't want to just
film the play i want to make this a
movie but he wisely stated that we can't
open it up and go out on the streets
because we were given about a million
seven to do the movie and the mandate
was to shoot it in ten days
so he said but let's use the interior of
the aquarius the entire movie was shot
inside the aquarius theater with the
exception of the opening scene when the
when the low rider
vehicles come up and the the stock stock
shots of the sleepy lagoon
so luis used the
block the box seats to create the radio
station and the chase scenes were in the
audience and the bar
and so forth so
what happened was um
we had to get more money we had to get a
little more money and so the other 14
fortuitous event was meeting vernafields
who was the head of post-production at
universal and she really latched on to
our idea and became our champion and so
we would go to her and she would go up
to ned tannen's office and beg for my
money and we kept begging for more money
and more money and then finally got to
what i presumed was maybe going to be
the last trip and at the same time
verner was helping us she was helping
spielberg shoot inserts for jaws in his
in her pool in her backyard in encina
so he went to ned's office i don't know
if you remember about ned would sit
there and listen to us and always very
kind and
canon
exactly and uh
so in the middle of the conversation ned
gets up from his desk and starts walking
out of the room i said hey he's going to
take us down to accounting and give us a
boatload of money
but i guess we better follow him so we
did we get to the elevator and he
pushes the button
and the doors open up and you sit there
okay it's time to ask for more money or
do we get on the elevator and
be grateful for what we've got and there
really was no option you get on the
elevator
so a little while later i went up to
luis and i said i'm sorry luis we
couldn't get any more money i guess
we're going to have to do this with what
we have and he turned to me with those
sympathetic eyes and said peter don't
worry
i started theater
on the back of a great picker's truck
with cardboard cutouts
i know that limitation is part of the
creative process until somebody sets the
edge of my palette i can't begin to
paint
wow very nice
yes you did because i've quoted it many
times an interesting footnote is a
yeah vice president at universal at the
time also one of the editor of jaws
uh when in 1965
was teaching at ucla
and uh some of her students went to
delano
to film uh some scenes from the grape
strike and it just started and it so
happens that they were there on the very
day that i had the first meeting to
organize
campesino
and so she said i have some film about
you
would you like a copy i'll say yeah what
is it and she showed it to me and
i was that's fantastic i said that's the
very inception that's the moment that el
teatro was created in delano and so we
we got the copy you know 16 millimeter a
print of of her short film but she was
very very supportive ned tannen was very
supportive the uh this version was not
my original version you know i was like
everybody else i had delusions of
grandeur you know i'm going to make a
movie i want to make a movie damn it you
know so my uh conception was very much
like batman before batman
before batman came back but i had
skyscrapers i had the pachuco flying the
top you know and flying through the air
and we took it around and people would
tell me this is a 20 million movie
you're never going to get it done you
know unless you get another director i
said i want to direct it no forget it
you know so it came down to the reality
of universal studios ned tannen he said
we'll give you 750 thousand dollars to
film it on videotape
three camera shoot and then we'll blow
up the videotape to 35 millimeter film
and they showed me the gong show movie
and i said this is disgraceful you know
and i said it's got to be film so it
said fine we'll do it film so the
35 millimeter film
we brought on davey myers our
cinematographer great davey myers and he
discovered that what the studio had in
mind was they were going to bring the
old mitchell cameras out of mothballs
because everybody was doing panavision
now
and the mitchell cameras were 10 years
in retirement but they were going to
bring out those old 35 millimeter
cameras and let me use three of them
and he shamed them he said that's
disgraceful
so we i we ended up with three
panavision cameras
with three
and the first night my baptism by fire i
swear to you the first night that was
shot
again i was so into it you know that all
of this was ingrained i couldn't sleep
that first night but i did finally fall
asleep and what i dreamt it was i was in
bed with three 35 millimeter cameras
watching me
filming me sleeping you know i had to
wake up i said no this is ridiculous but
it was a baptism of fire that was aided
by a lot of good friends you know peter
purell
as a line producer as the hands-on guy
was absolutely instrumental in basic in
terms of turning our very limited
resources into what you see on film we
used every little every frame jacqueline
can tell you we were
in the bins looking for you know always
they've lost shot because we we were we
shot for 13 days we extended one day 13
days
and that was it it was my baptism of
fire you can shoot your first film if
you want
no stars
there weren't any stars maybe time daily
maybe john anderson maybe charles edmond
the world did not know edward james
almost yet
he was a star after they saw him right
on he was a star on broadway you know he
was nominated for a tony but not on film
but it was an amazing experience but
smith supervising editor was on the set
also and so i'm very grateful to the
team that we put together because it
takes collaboration and it takes egoless
collaboration to get something like this
done it was a labor of love for a lot of
people it is
it is um
it's impossible it's impossible to talk
about this film and not talk about its
modern relevance and their lines in the
play in the movie the lawyer i have
tried my best to defend what is most
precious in our american society a
society now at war against the forces of
racial intolerance and totalitarian
injustice when you look at this play and
this movie today i guess the question
for all of you
as horrible as it might sound is it even
more relevant today than the era in
which it was made
yeah i mean certainly
do being having the privilege of being
able to be part of the revival
it was palpable yet again
and the empowerment that the play was
giving to an audience and the release
that that audience felt
and the shame as well that here we are
again or still
um and
that is um
frightening
and and also
empowering to be able to do the theater
to give the gift of
resistance and resilience
that that the play holds now rose was in
the revival in january were you going to
bring that up i play in a slightly older
character
[Laughter]
yes i was going to bring that up
you got to see it from both sides
i brought it up she brought it up but
the fact is i mean that it was it's
relevant today we had a three-month run
you know at the at the mark taper forum
every performance sold out
uh to this day it is the highest
grossing production ever produced at the
at the music center by the center
theater group
and and the fact is that
there are some members of that new cast
that are present
rose played her the mother played hank's
mother i couldn't play dela no more
and danny my brother played uh hank's
father papa so that was a wonderful
comeback but we also have some of the
members of the cast are you there like
you see
stand up stand up take a bow just stand
up
alice tiffany you know
who played alice
melina
peter
peter mendoza mendoza played a number of
roles actually okay so thank you so much
but yes it's very relevant dangerously
so but you know uh there's more of us
now
yes and uh yes
i mean it's a fact of life you know a
friend chicago friend of mine said what
he tells anglos is we come in peace
but we have you surrounded you know
and uh and the fact is that in my
lifetime and i have to make this
reference
my dad your memory my dad was in
cimarron
with the first western that won the
academy at the first academy what
cimarron yeah we're talking about the
academy i wish my dad were here because
he was just a mule driver he and my
maternal grandfather were mule drivers
in the san joaquin valley that were
hired to drive the mules it's the
oklahoma land rush right so they hired
anybody that can handle a 16
mule team and so he was there and he
worked on that for a few days and he
always talked about the catering he said
we ate real well you know
and and and it's a classic film richard
dix and some of the others i mean but
it's an old western but as a little kid
he used to tell these stories and i
remember thinking well my dad made
movies i can make movies
see it's that again it's a legacy that's
passed on i did not know how difficult
it was going to be
but the fact is that the state of
california in my time my lifetime has
changed in 1940 when i was born the
population was 6 million altogether
there were less than a million chicanos
here
000. there were 120 000 japanese
american hundred thousand chinese
less than a hundred thousand african
americans so this was a very white
uh white anglo-saxon protestant state
now we're pushing toward 50 million in
20 years
and the fact is that 40 of those are
latinos and that's not even counting
asians that's not even counting all of
the varied races of the world that have
come to california and to los angeles
particularly this is an international
global city
and so there's an understanding on the
street there's an understanding in the
neighborhoods what this movie is about
and what we're really talking about but
there is a recalcitrant re
reactive
minority
that is feeling inferiority complex and
if you're any complex that i i know
unless people say white power white
supremacy that's not white supremacy
that's white inferiority
that's a white inferiority complex
and and trump our president has a a
vicious imperiality complex
i know that because i got well
acquainted with inferiority complexes as
i was growing up and you puff yourself
up you try to make yourself bigger than
you are and that's what he's doing all
those people are so afraid of other
peoples and he said we got to defend our
white people are crazy
because they're overwhelmed the world is
is a globe
and we're all connected to each other
and this is why i think that zoo perhaps
will speak to future generations for a
little while longer i think so yes
uh edward
edward my last question is for you this
is pacific standard time lala latin
american and latino art in los angeles
this movie obviously meant a lot to you
as a professional actor what do you
think this movie means in terms of what
it established for latino cinema and
what the future holds for latino cinema
it's been
a growth process that's getting stronger
it's getting harder um there's more of
us now like that's been said
so um
and the it hasn't changed
uh we were
back 50 years ago or even 25 years ago
we were maybe
what
i don't know maybe
we're now over 65 million latinos in
this
country
they say we're 55
but we're well past that
25 years ago we might have been at maybe
30.
we were 2
of the images that we saw on the screen
today we're
over let's let's take their number 55
million and we're less than four percent
four percent of all roles on tel on film
right and film right i'm going to talk
about film
it's it's been uh it's getting harder
and i think like like
you know we come in peace but we have
you surrounded
you may borrow that any time you go you
don't got it i got it i got it i got it
it's part of it i got it i got it
it it is important i think to to just
look at
this film all of us were naive and young
and babies and knew that we were artists
and and passionate and and
had
know what we were the first
we were all the first
there was no one to teach us to guide us
nimono we were just a la brava
all of us
look at the credits i'm sorry i'm way at
the end in the back
that's insulting
but that's what it took in order for me
to do the movie
in order for me to take this shot
that kind of thing i think doesn't quite
happen
now because there are more of us
there are more of us who have mentors
aqui
who go you don't stand up for that
[ __ ] no more there's one thing
that's really important too that luis
luis made it very clear at the outset
there will be no natalie woods playing
latinos
absolutely not
we could talk all night but the night is
over so i want to thank you for showing
up i do want to have one wait luis is
going to have the last word go ahead
louise
the impact of zootoot uh in latin
america is important uh this one opened
the gates the doors of mexico yep yeah
it brought walls down for me
believe it or not and so i was able to
go and do the world premiere thanks to
alma tambien with the the national
theater company in mexico city in 2010
but there had been interest already a
whole new generation of mexican
filmmakers some of which are some of
whom are earning
i mean
and el chivo you know who's gotten two
academy awards already the
cinematographer
three okay well i met these people i met
these guys in mexico city back in the
80s and they had all seen zoot suit
and so uh
when i started to uh cast um
la bamba years later in 85 86
um
i made a contact with uh an actor that
was afraid a favorite of mine is
emilio elindo fernandez do you know who
he is
okay great director great actor
also the model for oscar
wow that's his body
and so uh
he said he he loved the film he loved
uh he said something i i got
to a different party he told me
that
is what they said
your film has balls it's what he said
unlike an oscar and that's what i like
i'm sure it was not a lindy's fault you
know but anyway the the so i i said and
i dared i dared to venture that would
you be willing to do a small part in my
next film
and he said oh yes absolutely just send
me the script you know so in between the
time that i was able to get the script
to him he was in an auto accident that
finally killed him
he was on a motorcycle okay
and a guy in his 80s
and uh and so he was i could no longer
talk to him i had to talk to his wife
but he was dying
but i communicated to him that i was
still interested
i said get off the bed and come to l.a
and i'll put you in the film
but he said i'll be there
he didn't make it
he died
and it just as well because the part was
played by felipe cantu one of the
founders of campecino it doesn't matter
you know
the snake man the snake man in lavamba
the guy with the rattlesnakes that was
the role i was offering him but for me
it would have been the closing of a huge
circle because as a kid i used to see
mexican movies that he had directed and
starred in and had impacted my life and
i was very proud as a chicano that i was
returning the favor to mexico yes
especially contacting the original oscar
and now here we are at the academy and i
know elino fernandez is in heaven
laughing it up and having tequila's man
with everybody else
rose edward alma peter
louise thank you all thank you guys for
coming out
you